Welcome back everyone
Happy Holidays
Marvel just announced that they're firing
Jonathan Majors as their Kang in the MCU movies,
leaving them with a giant hole in the next two Avengers
movies for the villains that they were going to use.
Avengers five was literally called Kang Dynasty.
And even though Avengers six was originally supposed
to be Secret Wars and give them an opportunity
to move past the Kang character in all of his variants,
if they wanted to.
there was actually report when it was announced
that he had been fired that Marvel was going to move on
that even faster,
they're getting ready to cast Avengers five
and they've stopped calling it Kang Dynasty
as part of all these castings
and all the work that they're doing,
the pre-production, actual Marvel Studios
behind the scenes,
meaning that they'll use some other subtitle
for Avengers five and ultimately use it
to focus on some other characters.
lot of people have some ideas
about who this is going to be.
But Variety and a couple trades
actually reported on this
a couple months ago, Marvel's contingency plan.
So we'll break it all down because there are
a few obvious options for Marvel that most of
you have been asking about, like characters in general,
that they would replace Kang with.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos,
Whatever they wind up doing.
Of course I'll do videos for it.
January is probably going to be a huge month
for announcements
about all of these big changes that Marvel is making.
You have questions?
Yes, I had a lot of questions.
I'm sure you had a lot of questions.
But rest assured, we're going to answer them right now.
even though everything that happened with Jonathan
Majors is a really big deal,
like it's a really big surprise
how this is all going down.
There were a lot of other reasons
for them to want to move past the Multiversal movies
that they're in right now.
Just just in general, The last couple of years, Marvel
has been taking it in the butt.
they really want to move on to something new.
And that's something new is the X-Men movies.
Essentially, they're meant to replace all of the stuff
that's happening right now.
Like all these characters, they just want to move
past it onto fresh things that don't feel like
they're trying to recycle the same old ideas
over and over again for like, the last ten years.
I just did a video last week
about why Marvel fired Jonathan Majors.
It's a very complicated situation.
Like there's no one reason why they did after
an entire year of everybody just waiting to find out
how they were going to deal with his legal situation
now that they have let him go as their Kang.
He was also playing
all the other variants of Kang in the Council of Kangs
like all these other people that the characters
reportedly they're changing Avengers five.
And the big news is that they're probably
just going to turn secret Wars into a two part movie
so that they can start the Secret War
storyline in Avengers five
and they don't have to wait
a couple more years till Avengers 6
I've talked about this previously, but Marvel behind
the scenes actually fired the writer of Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty was Jeff Loveless.
He was the guy that wrote Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania.
He wrote that Kang the Conqueror Post-Credits
scene for that is that is like his script for Avengers
five was the counsel of Kang is coming for The Avengers
with all these different variants
played by Jonathan Majors in at some point.
Earlier this year, Marvel just decided
that they wanted to move past that like they
okay, we need to find something else to do
then there was a moment that was actually really quiet,
but I think it was them revealing that they were just
going to turn secret wars into a two part movie.
So what they did is they fired Jeff LUNDEN
as a couple months ago, and they hired Michael Waldron,
who had already been writing Avengers Secret Wars,
which was going to be their Avengers six.
he was brought on to rewrite Avengers five.
And I think the part of that was them
just expanding the secret War storyline
so that it encompassed two different movies,
even though they'll still call Avengers
five in Avengers six to completely different things.
Like right now it's secret
Wars, Part one, Secret Wars, Part two.
But they did the exact same thing with Avengers
Infinity War several years ago,
before they changed the title of the second movie
to Avengers Endgame.
Secret Wars also gives them the opportunity
to have a vastly different type
of villain
in for it to actually make sense for the story.
this also gives them a bunch of extra time to do a much
better adaptation of the secret war storylines.
In the comics.
There are two different versions,
one from the 1980s and one from the more recent comics.
If you haven't watched Spider-Man
the animated series, it's an amazing series
because they actually did a version of the Secret Wars
comic book eighties storyline during that,
with Spider-Man being brought to a version
about a world assembling a team,
fighting against a bunch of villains
like they did in the eighties.
Comics, who spot that Dr.
Doom guy before and why?
Of course. Computer.
Can I transport to this planet?
The Fantastic Four?
The affirmative.
There's another team of superheroes
that I've worked with before.
Computer, bring me one of the X-Men.
Which one?
Good question.
during the commentary for Doctor Strange
to Multiverse of madness.
They even revealed that they had started
to set up the character here
when they were doing all the fantastic
for stuff like this early on.
They were already starting to set up
Doctor Doom personal interest.
Pleasure
to work with Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four.
So is John.
Steven.
teleportation device
he uses to get into the scene That's Dr.
Tombs.
Doctor Doom's time door itself
appreciate your platform, Stephen,
but it's not the Scarlet Witch that we fear
That's the voice of Michael Waldron, the person I said
they just hired to write Avengers
five or rewrite Avengers five.
the more recent version of Secret Wars
was a much bigger storyline
and got Emperor Doom
was the main antagonist of that story.
Like the focal point of that story,
even though there were a bunch of other villains
from other Marvel movies
that wound up in that story, so doing.
The two part secret wars just avoids them
having to double down on the Council of Kangs
in Avengers five if they want to move past them
really quickly, which I think that they probably will
there's also been talk about them
recasting the council of Kangs like all these different
main variants that they were going to have to use
my take on all this is they spent so much time
developing the Council of Kangs
as a main thread coming after the Avengers.
They had to address them in at least some way.
they can't just do like the last couple of movies
before Avengers five than Avengers five without ever.
Speaking of the name Kang ever again,
or the Council of Kangs,
you need at least one big scene
showing some other character,
killing them off, setting them up as the bigger threat
here's the thing, though.
Some of you actually probably figured this out.
The other Trey's published a report a while ago
that internally at Marvel's last big story retreat,
where each year
they decide the future of all the Marvel movies
they'd already discussed pivoting to Doctor Doom
in the Marvel movies away from the main character.
And this was months and months ago that this happened.
there are a lot of reasons why they were discussing
moving away from the Kang character,
and a lot of it involved them just kind of waiting
to see what was happening with Jonathan Majors.
of all the viable options that Marvel has them
like characters that they could use, that people
could identify with, that work on different story
levels, like really high concept levels,
but also on ground level,
like more earth based stories.
Doctor Doom is probably one of their best options.
He's one of the few characters that works in
pretty much any type of story that you want to do.
He's a man of magic, a man of science.
so he'd even work as an Iron Man villain.
And this really blew your minds.
Before Robert Downey Jr was cast as iron Man
in the first Iron Man movie, they actually revealed
Kevin Foggy, Jon Favreau, that he was actually up
to play the original version of Dr.
they're just going to shows you
where their headspace is
for all those movies like this character just works
as so many different types of characters.
He'd work as a doctor.
Strange villain like Magic Bay's villain just as well
and because of his backstory,
he also works a lot like the Loki character.
somebody who starts out with good intentions,
but then slowly begins to break bad.
And you understand why he's doing all these bad things.
He feels like he has to do them,
like he's gone too far to do anything else.
we'll talk more about this in a second, too,
because Loki obviously probably
one of the best characters in the MCU,
one of the best arcs in the MCU.
They've used him as both a villain and a hero.
but the really big problem that Marvel has right now
with that and a lot of you realize
there's been a lot of people commenting about this
just in general how do they develop him?
Well enough to work as the antagonist of an Avengers
movie, Loki had the benefit
of being a main character in the first Thor movie
before he was in that first Avengers movie.
they had to give Dr. Doom the same treatment.
But is it also happens they've already given themselves
the opportunity to do this,
they've only publicly confirmed what some of their
movies a little further out are going to be.
But they did announce
that they were actually working on Doctor
Strange three in the movie was originally meant
to be one of the final movies before Secret
War started, if not the final movie before it started.
Like Doctor Strange, Three Ends and Boom, Secret Wars.
were originally going to use that
to finish paying off all the incursions storyline
with the remaining universe is being destroyed.
That was what that post-credits scene in Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness
was all about setting up the incursion storyline.
they were also going to weave in the comic book
Secret Wars Plot with Battle World.
The Beyond was collapsing. The remaining universes.
in at least before all the drama with Jonathan Majors,
with the Council of Kangs,
they were going to replace the beyond
from the more recent secret wars with the idea
of the Council of Kangs being behind all this.
what they can do now is just make Dr.
Doom one of the second leads in Doctor Strange three
and use it to explain how he's a sorcerer
just like Doctor Strange
and they can use part of Doctor strange three to adapt
at least some of the triumph and torment storyline
so that the audience begins
to sympathize with Doctor Doom
because there's a story all about he and Doctor Strange
trying to go to hell to save his mother's soul
just like Loki.
You kind of understand a little bit
about where his character came from,
why he's doing all these terrible things.
You just need some of the beats of that story so that
you understand why it is he's seeking all this power.
and he becomes the main antagonist of a secret Wars
storyline.
Either just Avengers five or you could doom
for both Avengers five and Avengers six.
But let me know in the comments.
If Marvel has to pivot from the main character
like they're going to kill off the Council of Kangs
either at the beginning of or right before Avengers
five, Who do you want them to replace the Kangs with?
Like who is going to be the new main antagonist
when Avengers five picks up?
There's a bunch of stuff coming up.
We're in the middle of Marvel's
What If episodes I'm doing videos for,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click here for that Deadpool three teaser
with all those X-Men characters
and click here to learn
why Marvel fired Jonathan Majors.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe and happy holidays!